This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Whether or not you believe in them, you probably have ghosts that haunt you. Not something sinister, but something you just can't get rid of. These ghosts are relentless and they will make you rehash details from your past, over and over again. Hi there, Sean Carr and friends. Hello, Sean Carr. Hi. I was calling about, hopefully I sang it,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。无论你是否相信鬼魂，你可能都有缠绕着你的“心魔”。它们并非邪恶之物，而是你无法摆脱的东西。这些心魔纠缠不休，会让你一遍又一遍地咀嚼过去的细节。你好，肖恩·卡尔和朋友们。你好，肖恩·卡尔。你好。我打电话来是想说，希望我唱出来了，
regardless of how few, so I won't list all of them. My boyfriend of a year and I ended our relationship. It's just looking back and thinking that I could have done better and I didn't. All these things keep popping in my head of small things, maybe something I should have said differently or something I should have done differently in a particular conversation or on a particular event. It makes me cringe with regret and shame.
不管有多少，所以我不会一一列举。我和交往了一年的男友分手了。回首往事，总觉得我本可以做得更好，但我没有。脑海中不断浮现出各种琐事，也许是我在某次谈话或某件事中应该换种说法或做法。这让我因后悔和羞愧而感到局促不安。
I have an affair. Everyone knows that it's not a secret, but it's a regret. My great regret is leaving Woodstock on Saturday morning. I was an evangelical Christian at the time. And I remember my friends asking me if I thought they were going to hell. And I told them that I thought they would go to hell if they did not become Christian. And it's something that's bothered me for the last 10 years. I am experiencing regrets on sometimes admitted by minute basis. And it is the biggest regret of my life, honestly.
我有过一段婚外情。大家都知道，这不是秘密，但却是一件憾事。我最大的遗憾是周六早上离开伍德斯托克。当时我是一名福音派基督徒。我记得朋友们问我，是否认为他们会下地狱。我告诉他们，如果他们不信奉基督教，就会下地狱。这件事困扰了我十年。我有时甚至每分钟都在经历后悔。老实说，这是我一生中最大的遗憾。
I hope you have a great rest of your day. Bye. Today on Hidden Brain, we're going to conclude our annual YouTube.0 series with a look at regrets. Why our tendency to dwell on the past may actually be helping us to prepare for the future? Amy Somerville is a senior research scientist at Cairo's research. When we spoke with her, she was a psychology professor running the regret lab at Miami University of Ohio.
祝你余下的一天过得愉快。再见。今天在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将通过探讨“遗憾”来结束我们的年度系列节目。为什么我们沉溺于过去的倾向实际上可能有助于我们为未来做准备？艾米·萨默维尔是开罗研究中心的高级研究科学家。当我们采访她时，她是俄亥俄州迈阿密大学心理学教授，负责管理遗憾实验室。
I don't know that I have a particular deep backstory about how I got into regret. I actually was just generally interested in social psychology. And one of the things that then drew me to regret from that is the fact that regret is among our most common emotions. By some estimates, it's the second most common emotion mentioned in daily life, and the most common negative emotion that we mention. And so this is really a pervasive part of how people experience the world around them. And as I learned more, I really started to realize that regret is actually a very hopeful emotion. It's something that is helping us learn from our mistakes and do better in the future. So it's actually, I think, a really positive thing to get to study.
我不觉得我有什么关于如何进入遗憾研究领域的特别深刻的背景故事。我其实只是对社会心理学普遍感兴趣。而让我从社会心理学转向研究遗憾的原因之一是，遗憾是我们最常见的情绪之一。据估计，它是日常生活中提到次数第二多的情绪，也是我们提到的最常见的负面情绪。所以，这确实是人们体验周围世界的一个普遍部分。随着我了解得越多，我真的开始意识到，遗憾实际上是一种非常有希望的情绪。它能帮助我们从错误中学习，并在未来做得更好。所以我认为，研究它实际上是一件非常积极的事情。
Amy, I'd like to structure this conversation around a couple of stories of regret. We actually reached out to listeners of Hidden Brain some time ago and they sent in stories about some of the things they regret in life. One came from Tom Bond's saint of Arlington, Virginia. Here's the tape. I regret not taking the lead in a school play when I was in ninth grade. I was in a 9 through 12 school and I was surprised to receive a lead as a freshman that was somewhat of a big deal considering that freshmen typically don't get those sort of roles and rather than accept the fact that the director felt like I would be a good choice for the role. I listened to people who said that I probably couldn't handle it and therefore decided to
艾米，我想围绕几个关于遗憾的故事来展开这次谈话。前段时间我们联系了《Hidden Brain》的听众，他们发来了关于生活中遗憾之事的感言。其中一个来自弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的汤姆·邦德·圣。这是录音。我遗憾的是在九年级时没有在学校戏剧中担任主角。我当时在一所9到12年级的学校，作为新生能得到主角让我很惊讶，考虑到新生通常不会得到那样的角色，这算是一件大事。但我没有接受导演认为我能胜任这个角色的事实，而是听信了那些说我可能应付不来的人的话，因此决定
turn the role down. Later on in life I realized that when people present me with an opportunity like that, if they have the confidence in me being able to be successful, they're likely not putting me in that place to fail. And so since then I feel like I've gotten a new confidence. And so when faced with a similar situation in the current dice, I've been much more likely to put my hand up and say yes. I'm wondering how common this is.
拒绝了这个角色。后来我意识到，当人们给我提供这样的机会时，如果他们相信我能成功，他们很可能不会把我放在一个注定失败的位置。所以从那以后，我觉得我获得了一种新的自信。因此，当现在面临类似情况时，我更有可能举手说“我愿意”。我想知道这种情况有多普遍。
Are people really good at taking what happened in the past and learning from it? What spells the difference between people who actually are behaving like Tom, taking a bad experience and saying, I'm actually going to use it, and people who just sort of stay stuck in what that bad experience was and think about it over and over again? So I think the thing that really characterizes it is less about necessarily what kind of person you are, but rather the way that you're experiencing these thoughts. So, there's something called rumination, which actually comes literally from bovine digestion, the idea of how cows vomit back up things, chew them over, swallow them back down, and
人们真的擅长从过去发生的事情中吸取教训吗？是什么导致了那些真正像汤姆那样，从糟糕的经历中吸取教训并说“我要利用它”的人，与那些仅仅困在糟糕经历中并反复思考的人之间的差异？我认为真正体现这种差异的，与其说是一个人的性格，不如说是你体验这些想法的方式。有一种东西叫“反刍”，它实际上字面意思源自牛的消化过程，即牛如何把食物吐出来、咀嚼、再咽下去，
so on and so forth. And in terms of our thoughts, it's actually this idea of the same kind of process that rumination is having thoughts sort of spring unwanted to mind, and we're chewing them over without actually getting anything new out of them. They're just repeatedly, intrusively becoming sort of part of our mental landscape. And what we found is that people who have intrusively becoming part of our mental landscape. And what we found is that people who have room-initive regrets, so that they're both having this regret, but also having it be something that's intrusive and repeated, tend to be people who are also experiencing the most negative outcomes.
如此循环往复。就我们的思想而言，这实际上是同样的过程，即反刍是指那些不请自来的想法涌入脑海，我们反复咀嚼它们，却无法从中获得任何新的东西。它们只是反复地、侵入性地成为我们心理图景的一部分。我们发现，那些有反刍式遗憾的人，即他们既有这种遗憾，又让这种遗憾变得侵入性和重复性，往往也是经历最负面结果的人。
So are more likely to have clinical depression symptoms, anxiety symptoms, things like that. There are some regrets you can learn from, like Tom's story about trying out for the school play, but other regrets feel harder to overcome. I asked Amy some of her about this and I played her the story from Catherine Wiginton Green, a listener from Washington DC. My main regret, what popped into my mind when I heard this on the podcast, was regretting not stopping and seeing my estranged father. He'd been estranged for our family for quite a while, and I had not seen him or spoken
所以他们更有可能出现临床抑郁症状、焦虑症状等。有些遗憾是可以从中学习的，比如汤姆关于参加学校戏剧试镜的故事，但其他遗憾则感觉更难克服。我问了艾米关于这一点，并给她播放了来自华盛顿特区听众凯瑟琳·威金顿·格林的故事。我主要的遗憾，当我在播客中听到这个话题时，脑海中浮现的是后悔没有停下来去见我疏远的父亲。他与我们家疏远了很长一段时间，我也没有见过他或与他交谈
with him in a very long time, his choice. And I was driving along Barcrete Parkway, who is my boyfriend at the time, who is now my husband. And as we were driving up Barcrete Parkway, I looked to my right and saw him and the woman he married, walking arm and arm. And I saw him and I told my husband to pull over immediately without thinking. And when we stopped the car, I started to unbuckle my feet belt. And then I stopped and paused
过，这是他的选择。当时我正和当时的男友（现在的丈夫）开车行驶在巴克雷特大道上。当我们开车经过时，我向右看，看到了他和他的妻子手挽手走着。我看到了他，没多想就告诉丈夫立刻靠边停车。当我们停下车时，我开始解开安全带。然后我停顿了
for a moment and realized I had no idea what I was going to do or what I was going to say. So I chicked out and buckled my seatbelt back and told my husband to keep driving, and then I burst into tears. And I realized that that was probably the last time I was going to see him, and that was my only chance to talk to him again. So I still regret that. There's something really point in about that story, Amy, because in this case it doesn't sound as if the regret has the potential for learning. She says that she feels that the door was closed in terms of her ability to reconnect with her father and she comes back to this memory over and over again,
片刻，意识到我根本不知道自己要做什么或说什么。所以我退缩了，重新系好安全带，告诉丈夫继续开车，然后我泪流满面。我意识到那可能是我最后一次见到他，那是我再次与他交谈的唯一机会。所以我至今仍为此感到遗憾。艾米，那个故事里有一些非常令人心酸的东西，因为在这种情况下，遗憾似乎并没有学习的潜力。她说她觉得与父亲重新建立联系的大门已经关闭，她一遍又一遍地回到这段记忆中，
and just remembers it as an opportunity that was lost. Yeah, certainly in terms of the specific incidents that we regret, they do seem to be most likely things where we had this opportunity in the moment, but it's not something that we can go back and fix, because obviously, if we could just magically go back and fix. Because obviously, if we could just magically turn back and fix something, then most people would do that rather than continue to regret it. What I might say is that I would imagine that one of the reasons that this does wrinkle for this woman is that it's about something that's important to
只是把它当作一个失去的机会来怀念。是的，就我们遗憾的具体事件而言，它们确实最可能是我们在当时有机会，但却无法回去修复的事情。因为显然，如果我们能神奇地回去修复某件事，那么大多数人都会那样做，而不是继续遗憾。我想说的是，我可以想象，这个女人之所以对此耿耿于怀，是因为这关乎她生命中重要的事情，
her, it's about her family. And that perhaps this is something that she can carry forward in terms of how she handles other relationships going forward. So I've heard people say that there are anecdotal reports that the things that people really regret are the things that they didn't do rather than the things that they did do. Is that just anecdotal?
关乎她的家庭。也许这可以成为她未来处理其他人际关系时的一种借鉴。我听说过人们说，轶事报告显示，人们真正遗憾的是他们没有做的事情，而不是他们做了的事情。这只是轶事吗？
Is that not actually true? That people regret acts of omission more than acts of commission? I would say there's some evidence for that. So one of the more famous studies on this thought about this in terms of something that happens over time. And what those researchers argued is that we regret things we did a lot more in the moment. So if you say something really stupid in a job interview, you're going to walk out and have that hand to the forehead feeling of, oh, why did I say that? That was such a terrible thing to have said in that moment.
这实际上不是真的吗？人们对“不作为”的遗憾多于对“作为”的遗憾？我会说这有一些证据支持。关于这个想法，最著名的研究之一是从时间跨度来考虑的。那些研究人员认为，在当下，我们对做过的事情感到遗憾更多。所以，如果你在面试中说了非常愚蠢的话，你走出来时会有一种拍额头的感觉：“噢，我为什么要那样说？在那一刻说出那样的话真是太糟糕了。”
But in the long run, we tend to have things that are kind of incomplete goals, stick around in our memory as kind of a mental to-do list, basically. And that as a result, our inactions wind up getting kind of added to that mental to-do list. So this may be something where, if you ask me, you know, what could you have done instead of going to grad school? I have this whole range of possibilities. I could have been a doctor, I could have been a writer, I could have backpacked around Europe and found my passion. And if you ask me, what are the things that you did yesterday that you could undo, right? I have a
但从长远来看，我们往往会有一些未完成的目标，像一份心理待办事项清单一样留在我们的记忆中。结果，我们的“不作为”最终被添加到了那份心理待办事项清单中。所以这可能就是，如果你问我，你知道，除了读研你还能做什么？我有一整套的可能性。我可以成为一名医生，我可以成为一名作家，我可以去欧洲背包旅行并找到我的热情所在。如果你问我，你昨天做的哪些事情是可以撤销的？我生活中实际做过的事情是
finite set of things I actually did in my life. And so over time it may be that when we're trying to undo something bad that's happened to us, it's easy to start imagining all of the things we might have done in the past because we have a lot more of those available to us than the things we actually did. There are times when we don't take responsibility for our actions, but at other times, we hold ourselves accountable for things that are outside our control. James Cooper of Pittsburgh shared one of those stories with us. My biggest regret is not listening to my father tell me about the mundane things that happened to him during the day and instead just immediately asking for my mom when I called the house and maybe when I talked to him I could have picked up on some other signs too and could have maybe
有限的。所以随着时间的推移，当我们试图撤销发生在我们身上的坏事时，很容易开始想象我们在过去可能做的所有事情，因为我们拥有的那些可能性比我们实际做过的事情要多得多。有时我们不对自己的行为负责，但有时，我们却为超出我们控制范围的事情承担责任。匹兹堡的詹姆斯·库珀与我们分享了其中一个故事。我最大的遗憾是，当我打电话回家时，没有听父亲跟我讲他白天发生的琐事，而是直接找我妈妈。也许如果我当时和他多聊聊，我本可以捕捉到一些其他的迹象，也许可以
prevented his suicide. You know when I heard James's story Amy I wondered whether you know if he had spoken to his father more would he have actually picked up on his father's mental health and even if he had noticed could he have actually stopped his father from committing suicide and it seemed to be that in this case james might have been taking on more responsibility then was actually warranted i mean it's understandable certainly at an emotional level but you've done some research looking at how sometimes when it comes to regret we take on more responsibility than we should yeah i think i would say exactly that.
阻止他的自杀。你知道，当我听到詹姆斯的故事时，艾米，我很好奇，如果他当时和父亲多说说话，他真的能察觉到父亲的心理健康状况吗？即使他注意到了，他真的能阻止父亲自杀吗？看起来在这种情况下，詹姆斯可能承担了比实际应承担的更多的责任。我的意思是，这在情感层面上是可以理解的，但你做过一些研究，观察到有时在遗憾方面，我们承担了不该承担的责任。是的，我想我完全同意这一点。
I think that this is a case of probably imagining that there's more that could have happened differently. And it's certainly the case as well that I think people often tend to focus a lot on their own actions about negative events. And it's probably important to think about the fact that you're just one agent in a much bigger framework that his father had other friends, hopefully had doctors, had his mother, and that it's not just on James to have recognized these symptoms, but that there were lots of other pieces that could have played out differently,
我认为这是一个典型的例子，人们可能想象有更多的事情本可以以不同的方式发生。而且确实，我认为人们往往倾向于在负面事件中过多地关注自己的行为。思考这样一个事实可能很重要：你只是一个更大框架中的一个参与者，他的父亲还有其他朋友，希望还有医生，还有他的母亲。不仅仅是詹姆斯一个人应该识别出这些症状，还有很多其他因素可能会导致不同的结果，
not just his own actions, but a broader set of things that could have changed. Is there a way for people to look at their regrets and say, this is the kind of regret that is actually useful and productive, and this is the kind of regret that is actually useful and productive, and this is the kind of regret that is actually better set aside. So I would say that we know that people tend to generate these what-if thoughts as a way of trying to understand their experiences and as a way of trying to bring control to things that feel uncontrollable. We don't like the idea that bad things happen with no reason and without the ability to predict them. And in the case of regret, I think it can be that in James's case, for instance, not wanting to think about this tremendous loss as
不仅仅是他自己的行为，还有更广泛的一系列可能改变的事情。人们有没有办法审视自己的遗憾并说，这种遗憾是有用且富有成效的，而那种遗憾最好放下？我会说，我们知道人们倾向于产生这些“如果……会怎样”的想法，以此作为试图理解自身经历的一种方式，也是作为试图对那些感觉无法控制的事情施加控制的一种方式。我们不喜欢坏事发生却毫无理由且无法预测的想法。在遗憾的情况下，我认为，以詹姆斯的例子为例，不想把这种巨大的损失看作是
something that wasn't predictable and wasn't controllable, that it's, I think, very reassuring sometimes to try to come up with an explanation of, there's a way that this could have been prevented, it could have been changed, and it feels less random and less senseless in that way. senseless in that way. You know, I'm fascinated by what you just said, because essentially what you're saying is that the fear or the pain of having a world that seems, you know, without meaning or is unexplainable or unpredictable, that pain of that might actually be greater than the pain of taking on regrets for things that you actually maybe don't have responsibility for and experiencing personal anguish about it. That's a fascinating idea. Yeah, there's been research that says one of the ways that people can get a sense of control over their
一种不可预测且不可控制的事情，有时试图得出一个解释——即“如果当时怎样，这件事本可以被预防、被改变”——是非常令人宽慰的。这样一来，它感觉就不那么随机、不那么毫无意义了。你知道，你刚才说的话让我很着迷，因为本质上你是在说，面对一个似乎没有意义、无法解释或不可预测的世界，那种恐惧或痛苦，可能比承担那些你实际上可能没有责任的事情的遗憾，并为此经历个人痛苦的痛苦更大。这是一个迷人的观点。是的，有研究表明，人们获得对自身环境控制感的方式之一，就是产生这些关于“如果……会怎样”的想法。
circumstances is by having these thoughts about what might have been. The dark side of that, along with personal regret, is there is also work where things like victim blaming can actually come out of these thoughts about what might have been. So if you think about a woman who attended a party and drank a drink that had been drugged, and then was sexually assaulted, it's very easy to think about that one moment of she took this drink.
这种想法的阴暗面，除了个人遗憾之外，还有研究表明，像“受害者有罪论”这样的事情实际上也可能源于这些关于“如果……会怎样”的想法。所以，如果你想到一个参加聚会并喝了被下药的饮料，然后遭到性侵犯的女性，很容易想到那一刻——她喝了这杯饮料。
And if she had been more careful, then this assault might not have happened to her. And that that sort of gives us a sense of control, rather than the much more complicated thing to think about undoing of, well, how could we have prevented this person who gave her this drink and who committed this crime from doing it? So yeah, these thoughts about what might have been help give us a causal structure to our world, but sometimes they're not necessarily the correct or the most useful ways of thinking about causality. thinking about causality.
如果她当时更小心一点，那么这次袭击可能就不会发生在她身上。这给了我们一种控制感，而不是去思考更复杂的问题，比如：我们该如何阻止那个给她饮料并犯下罪行的人？所以，是的，这些关于“如果……会怎样”的想法有助于为我们的世界提供一种因果结构，但有时它们并不一定是正确或最有用的因果思考方式。
When we come back, a story of regret and karma. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. I'm back with Amy Somerville. Amy, let's listen to another story. This one comes from Tania Stark of Farmington, New Mexico. I'm going to play the story in two parts because I think it reveals two different sides of regret. One of my biggest regrets comes from something I did in the fifth grade, 20 or more years ago. I remember making fun of this little girl who was a bit overweight and me and another girl just teased her relentlessly.
稍后回来，一个关于遗憾和因果报应的故事。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。我与艾米·萨默维尔一起回来。艾米，让我们听听另一个故事。这个故事来自新墨西哥州法明顿的塔尼娅·斯塔克。我将分两部分播放这个故事，因为我认为它揭示了遗憾的两个不同侧面。我最大的遗憾之一源于我在五年级时做的一件事，那是20多年前的事了。我记得我嘲笑了一个有点超重的小女孩，我和另一个女孩无情地戏弄她。
And I think about some of the things that I said to her and some of the ways that I treated her. And I just regret how cruel I was as a child. And now that I'm older and I work in a field where I see the effects of bullying and meanness does to children. I am so full of regret in that. And if I could ever find her again or talk to her again because I've moved to three or four different places at this point in my life and have no idea where she is or if it even affected her, I regret the way that I treated her and I believe that I was so cruel. Amy, I want to talk about the role of guilt in regret. They seem closely tied these two emotions, but I don't think they're identical. Tom Bonsain from Arlington, Virginia, regretted that he didn't get the lead in his school play, but there was no guilt involved.
我想到我当时对她说的一些话以及我对待她的方式。我非常后悔自己小时候是多么残忍。现在我长大了，在这样一个领域工作，我看到了欺凌和刻薄对孩子造成的伤害。我对此充满了遗憾。如果我能再次找到她或与她交谈——因为我已经搬了三四个地方，根本不知道她在哪里，也不知道这是否真的影响了她——我后悔我对待她的方式，我相信我当时太残忍了。艾米，我想谈谈内疚在遗憾中的作用。这两个情绪似乎紧密相连，但我不认为它们是完全相同的。弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的汤姆·邦德·圣后悔没有在学校戏剧中担任主角，但这其中不涉及内疚。
Tanya, on the other hand, feels terrible about what she did. When you hear Tanya's story, are you hearing guilt or are you hearing regret? So listening to Tanya's story, I would say I hear both guilt and regret, and both regret and guilt are emotions that are based on a form of comparison. So regret, I'm comparing what really happened to some imagined alternative. And some of the time, that's all we feel, right? I just imagined that something could have been better. Guilt involves an additional comparison to what has been called our personal standards rules and goals.
另一方面，塔尼娅对她所做的事情感到非常糟糕。当你听到塔尼娅的故事时，你听到的是内疚还是遗憾？听了塔尼娅的故事，我会说我既听到了内疚也听到了遗憾。遗憾和内疚都是基于某种比较的情绪。所以遗憾是：我将现实发生的事情与某种想象的替代方案进行比较。有时，这就是我们所感受到的全部，对吧？我只是想象如果事情能更好就好了。内疚则涉及与所谓的“个人标准、规则和目标”的额外比较。
So what are the things that we aspire to in our behavior? And when we make a comparison that says what we really did, fall short of those personal standards, rules, or goals for ourselves, then we're likely to feel guilt. I want you to listen to the second part of Tanya's story. She told us that she fully realized what she had done to this other little kid, only when events in her own life took a turn. I think karma came and got me because while I was a petite little kid, as I got older and do some injuries, I became quite overweight myself and heard the comments that were said about me or how I became invisible and people didn't think that my feelings mattered. The heaviest I ever was was 330 pounds,
所以，我们在行为上追求的是什么？当我们进行比较并发现我们实际所做的未能达到那些个人标准、规则或目标时，我们很可能会感到内疚。我想请你听塔尼娅故事的第二部分。她说，直到她自己生活中发生了一些事情，她才完全意识到自己对那个小孩子做了什么。我想因果报应找上我了，因为虽然我小时候是个娇小的孩子，但随着年龄增长，由于一些伤病，我自己变得非常超重，也听到了别人对我的评论，或者我变得“隐形”，人们认为我的感受并不重要。我最重的时候有330磅，
and I have worked hard and have surgery and have lost. Quite a bit of weight, I'm just about 195 now, but I still see myself and still have the self-confidence of a 330 pound woman, and I know how it feels feels and I regret making anyone else ever feel that way. When you listen to Tanya's story, Amy, I'm wondering, do you hear sort of someone saying, I really don't like the way the world has treated me? Or do you hear someone saying, I realize the world has treated me really badly and that's opened my eyes to the way that I might have treated other people in the past.
我努力工作，做了手术，减掉了不少体重。我现在大约195磅，但我仍然以330磅女性的视角看待自己，也有着那样的自信心。我知道那种感觉，我后悔让任何人有过那种感受。艾米，当你听塔尼娅的故事时，我在想，你听到的是有人在说“我真的不喜欢这个世界对待我的方式”？还是听到有人在说“我意识到世界对待我非常糟糕，这让我大开眼界，看到了我过去可能对待别人的方式”？
It sounds like in Tanya's case she's really developed a different understanding of the world and used that to understand how her behavior may have affected other people rather than necessarily being a particularly focused on feeling that she's been treated badly. And I think that again, regret is based on this idea that we personally could have done something differently. And so in some ways, it's obviously a self-focused emotion. It's about what we should have done, but I think it can also be a fairly selfless emotion and be about how we relate to the people in the world around us. What responsibility do we have towards our fellow humans? [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing I wish that I could find this person and tell her about how I now regret what I did to
听起来在塔尼娅的案例中，她确实对世界有了不同的理解，并利用这一点来理解她的行为可能如何影响了其他人，而不是特别专注于感到自己受到了糟糕的对待。我认为，遗憾再次基于这样一个想法：我们个人本可以采取不同的行动。所以从某种程度上说，这显然是一种自我关注的情绪。它关乎我们本应该做什么，但我认为它也可以是一种相当无私的情绪，关乎我们如何与周围的人建立联系。我们对同胞负有什么责任？
her when we were children. And I think one of the things as well that's interesting about this whole episode is that you have listeners calling in to tell the whole world, millions of people who might listen to this podcast about their very personal, very private regrets. Psychologists have talked for a long time about something called the fundamental attribution era, which is how much do we believe actions of either ourselves or others are caused by things that are intrinsic to us, things that are part of our personalities, who we are, versus things that are shaped by the context, by the
我希望我能找到那个人，告诉她我现在是多么后悔我们小时候我对她所做的一切。我认为整个事件中另一个有趣的地方是，你有听众打电话来告诉全世界——数百万可能收听这个播客的人——他们非常个人、非常私密的遗憾。心理学家长期以来一直在谈论一种叫做“基本归因错误”的东西，即我们认为自己或他人的行为在多大程度上是由我们内在的东西（我们性格的一部分，我们是谁）造成的，而不是由环境（我们所处的境况）塑造的。当像塔尼娅这样的人作为成年人回顾她小时候的行为时，你认为基本归因错误在某种程度上是否导致我们相信自己要为那些我们可能并不负责的事情负责，也许当时真的是环境在驱动我们的行为？
situation in which we find ourselves. When someone like Tanya looks back as an adult at her behavior as a child, do you think the fundamental attribution at her plays a role in some ways leading us to believe that we are responsible for things that maybe we were not responsible for, that maybe really the context was driving our actions and behavior way back when?
是的，绝对是。再次重申，我认为遗憾基于一种个人责任感。当然，在西方文化中，人们非常相信个人要为自己的行为负责，我们要为自己的命运负责。我认为这会导致个人更多地思考
Yeah, absolutely. Again, I think regret is based on this sense of personal responsibility. And certainly in Western cultures, there's very much this belief that individuals are responsible for their own actions were responsible for our own destinies. And I think that can lead individuals to think more
某个特定的行为者（包括他们自己或其他人）是如何发挥作用的，而对整个环境的关注则少得多。所以在塔尼娅的故事中，我相信她开头提到，有一个她与之交好的小女孩和她一起参与了欺凌。我认为很容易忽略她当时承受同伴压力的程度。对吧？这种欺凌发生的社会背景可能并不原谅或宽恕它，但这并不一定仅仅关乎塔尼娅作为一个人的本质，而是一个更复杂的网络，影响着她以及当时作为那个人的她。我想谈谈“反事实”的概念。反事实当然是指我们想象事情本可以以不同于实际结果的方式发生。事实证明，我目前正在从运动损伤中恢复。当我想到我是如何受伤时，我唯一想到的就是：为了防止这次受伤，我本可以做些什么不同的事情？
about how a given actor, including themselves or including another person, played a role, and a lot less attention to the whole context. So in Tanya's story, I believe she started by talking about how there was another little girl that she was friends with who joined with her in the bullying. And I think it may be easy to ignore the degree to which she was experiencing peer pressure. Right? There was probably a social context in which this bullying occurred, which doesn't forgive
现在，大多数时候我进行体育运动时，我并不会问自己“为什么我没有受伤？”。所以你认为是什么导致我们在某个时间点去寻找特定的反事实，而在其他时间点却不这样做？我们谈论反事实时，认为它们有两个不同的方向。想象世界本可以变得更好的，我们称之为“上行反事实”；想象世界本可以变得更糟的，我们称之为“下行反事实”。
it or excuse it, but it's not necessarily just about who Otonia is as a person to have done this, but rather really a much more complicated net of things that were influencing her as well as who she was at that time. I want to talk about the idea of counterfactuals. A counterfactual, of course, is when we imagine that things could have turned out differently than they actually did. As it turns out, I'm recovering right now from a sports injury. When I think about how I got hurt, the only thing I'm thinking about is what could I have done differently to prevent this injury from happening?
当然，在生活中，上行反事实似乎占主导地位。我们似乎这样做的一个原因是，这些上行反事实有助于我们学习。所以如果你想到发生车祸，如果我说“如果我当时没有发短信，我就可能不会发生事故”，那就是在识别事故的一个特定原因。是发短信，而不是我的车速，或者当时在下雨，或者道路的工程设计和交通流设计。而下行反事实似乎服务于不同的功能，即它们让我们对可能发生的事情感觉更好。所以我的合作者Soyeon Rim和我发现，当人们专注于
Now most of the time when I play sports, I'm not asking myself why didn't I get hurt? So what do you think causes us to reach for certain counterfactuals at one point in time, but not for others? So we talk about counterfactuals as having two different directions. So things imagining how the world could have been better, we call upward counterfactuals, and imagining how the world could have been worse, we call downward counterfactuals.
……（此处音频缺失，根据上下文推断）……但对于那些感觉离我们更近的事情，即再次强调，是发生在我们个人身上而不是别人身上的事情，我们似乎往往更专注于让自己感觉更好。所以以你的伤为例，思考事情本可能比现在糟糕得多，这可能是有帮助的。你知道，你回到了工作岗位。希望你不需要太多的医疗干预或手术，你知道，那些本可能比仅仅留下扭伤或拉伤要糟糕得多。所以，我被汤姆·吉洛维奇多年前在巴塞罗那奥运会上所做的那个伟大的研究提醒了，他拍摄了站在奖牌台上的运动员的照片。他发现，当然，银牌得主倾向于进行这些上行反事实思考，他们往往看起来不那么快乐，因为他们希望自己赢得了金牌。
And certainly in life, upward counterfactuals seem to predominate. And one of the reasons that we seem to do this is that these upward kind of factuals are helping us learn. So if you think about getting into a car accident, if I say, you know, if only I hadn't been texting, then I might not have had the accident, that's identifying a particular cause of the accident. It was the texting and not my speed or the fact that it was raining or the way
而铜牌得主倾向于进行下行反事实思考。他们想象所有那些根本没有获得任何奖牌的人，并为自己能站在奖牌领奖台上感到宽慰。这很迷人，因为它是如何发生的，我们如何选择进行上行反事实还是下行反事实，这在很大程度上是无意识地发生的，然而这种无意识的选择对我们之后是否感到快乐有着巨大的影响。是的，特别是在奖牌例子中，塑造这一点的因素之一是：想象这种替代方案发生的可能性有多大？通常对于银牌得主来说，想象他们离金牌有多近要容易得多。而对于铜牌得主，最容易想象的事情
that the road was engineered and designed for traffic flow. And downward counterfactuals seem to serve a different function, which is that they make us feel better about the things that might have happened. And so my collaborator, Soyeon Rim, and I have found that when people are focused on So, I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am a moderator, so I am aprove. But for things that feel a little bit closer to us, so again, happening to us personally rather than to somebody else, those things we seem to be often somewhat more focused on feeling better about. And so with the example of your injury, it may be the case that it's helpful to think about how things could
是，根本没有站在奖牌台上，因为那些是实际上更接近的事情。我最喜欢的关于反事实的另一个研究是，如果你考虑一个成绩分布，获得A的门槛是90%或以上，课程中获得89分的学生最终比获得87分的学生更不满意。他们两个都是B+，但89分的学生，太容易
have turned out much worse than they did, that, you know, you're back at work. Hopefully, you didn't need a lot of medical intervention or surgery, you know, and those would have been things that would have been much, much worse than walking away with just maybe a sprain or a strain. So, I'm reminded of that great study that Tom Gilevich did many years ago at the Barcelona Olympics, where he took photographs of the people who were on the metal stand. And he found, of course, that the silver medalists tend to make these upward counterfactuals, and they tend to look a little less happy because they wish they had one goal.
想象如果能多得那一分会怎样，而对于87分的学生，他们往往觉得能达到现在的成绩很幸运，并没有想象他们本可能得到A-的情况。我听说你大约一年前结婚了，你在选择婚纱时应用了你自己关于遗憾的研究。是的。我其实并没有应用我自己的研究。
Whereas the bronze medalists tend to make downward counterfactuals. They imagine all the other people who didn't win any medals at all, and find themselves relieved that they find themselves in the medals podium in the first place. And this is fascinating because how this happens, how we choose to make the upward counterfactual or the downward counterfactual, this is largely happening unconsciously, and yet this unconscious choice has an enormous effect on whether we feel happy afterwards. Yeah, and one of the things that shapes particularly the metal example is how easy is it to imagine this alternative happening? So often for a silver metalist, it's much, much easier to imagine how close they were to getting gold. Whereas for a bronze medalist, the thing that's easiest to imagine
我应用了Shineyanger关于“选择过载”现象的研究，以及巴里·施瓦茨及其同事关于“最大化者”与“满足者”作为决策策略的想法——最大化者是指你想要从所有可能的替代方案中挑选最好的，而满足者是指你打算挑选一个符合你所有标准，但可能不一定是绝对最好的东西。所以当我去买婚纱时，我去了几家店，每家店试穿了五到十件礼服，
is, yeah, not being on the medal stand at all, because those are things that are actually closer. Another one of my favorite studies about counterfactuals is that if you think about a grade distribution where the cutoff to get an A is to get a 90% or above, students who get an 89 in a course wind up being less satisfied than the students who got an 87. Both of them have a B plus, but the 89s, it's so easy
我找到了一件我非常喜欢且在我的价格范围内的礼服，我意识到研究告诉我的结论是：我永远不会比那一刻更快乐。如果我继续逛礼服店，我最终会感到不知所措。你知道，我可以找到一百种不同的象牙色V领蕾丝礼服。我最终会因为分不清它们之间的区别而感到困惑。而试图获得绝对最好的行为本身，意味着我永远无法确定自己是否做到了。而如果我采取“满足者”策略，我可以确定我穿的是一件看起来很美且在我的价格范围内的礼服。
to just imagine how did you get just that one more point, whereas for the 87s, they tend to feel lucky that they wound up where they are and aren't imagining how they might have gotten the aim minus instead. I understand you got married about a year ago and you applied some of your own research on regret when it came to choosing a wedding dress. I did. I actually wasn't applying my own research.
去想象你究竟是如何多得那一分的，而对于87分的人来说，他们往往会觉得自己能达到现在的水平很幸运，而不会去想象自己是如何可能拿到A减的。我听说你大约一年前结婚了，在挑选婚纱时，你应用了自己关于遗憾的研究。是的，我确实应用了，不过不是我自己的研究。
I applied work by Shineyanger on the phenomenon of choice overload, as well as work by Barry Schwartz and colleagues about the idea of maximizing versus satisfying as strategies for decisions, maximizing being the idea that you want to pick the best of all possible alternatives and satisfying being the idea that you're going to pick something that meets all of your standards, but may or may not be the absolute best. So when I was wedding dress shopping, I went to a couple of stores, I tried on five or ten dresses at each one,
我应用了希娜·艾扬格关于选择过载现象的研究，以及巴里·施瓦茨及其同事关于最大化与满意化作为决策策略的观点。最大化是指你想要从所有可能的选择中挑选出最好的，而满意化是指你打算挑选出符合你所有标准的东西，但它未必是绝对最好的。所以当我去买婚纱时，我去了几家店，每家店都试穿了五到十件礼服，
and I found a dress that I absolutely loved and was in my price range, and I realized that what the research told me was, I would never be happier than I was at that moment. That if I kept rest shopping, I was going to wind up feeling overwhelmed. You know, I could find a hundred different lace sheaths with a v-neck in ivory. And I would wind up feeling confused about what are the differences between these. And that the very act of trying to get the absolute best would mean that I could never really be sure if I'd done it. Whereas if I adopted a satisfying strategy, I could be sure I'm in a dress that looks beautiful on me and is in my price range,
我找到了一件我非常喜欢且在预算范围内的礼服，我意识到研究告诉我的道理是，我永远不会比那一刻更快乐了。如果我继续逛下去，最终只会感到不知所措。你知道，我可以找到一百种不同的象牙色V领蕾丝紧身裙。最终我会对它们之间的区别感到困惑。而试图追求绝对最好的行为本身，意味着我永远无法确定自己是否做到了最好。然而，如果我采取满意化的策略，我就能确定我穿的这件礼服既漂亮又在我的预算范围内，
and I should just buy it and be done. And so that's how I chose my wedding dress. How I chose my wedding dress. Amy Somerville is a senior research scientist at Cairo's research. When we spoke with her, she was a psychology professor running the regret lab at Miami University of Ohio. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Christian Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our Ronsang Heroes this week are the program directors at NPR member stations around the country. Choosing the programs that run on a public radio station is very difficult.
我应该直接买下它，然后就完事了。这就是我选择婚纱的方式。我选择婚纱的方式。艾米·萨默维尔是开罗研究中心的一名高级研究科学家。当我们采访她时，她还是迈阿密大学俄亥俄分校的一名心理学教授，负责运营后悔实验室。《Hidden Brain》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯蒂安·黄、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。我们本周的幕后英雄是全国各地 NPR 成员电台的项目总监。选择在公共广播电台播放的节目是非常困难的。
There are so many different shows to choose from, and we're so grateful to the stations that have decided to bring Hidden Brain to their listeners. If you've enjoyed our U2.O series the past few weeks, please consider supporting our work. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有太多不同的节目可供选择，我们非常感谢那些决定将《Hidden Brain》带给听众的电台。如果您喜欢我们过去几周的 U2.O 系列节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。您可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 进行支持。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。下周见。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。